change hats so I want to thank the
organizers for inviting me and now we
will be talking about machine learning
yes five minutes anything you like it's
we have one hour free for people who are
not giving talks to actually speak about
something that the thing is important it
could be an open question and could be
comment on something else it will be a
new paper it could be something right
the idea is we want to start discussing
about things so think of it as an
opportunity to start the discussion with
other people who are here more than
announcing results okay good so so the
first session today is about machine
learning so as I said we will have a
couple of talks and then at the end
there will be a discussion and I start
with quantum machine learning prospects
and challenges so there are many
prospects and many challenges so let's
see so why should we look at quantum
machine learning well you kind of
already know how hyped machine learning
is and you can find all these fancy
pictures on the web about machine
learning then if you put quantum then it
becomes even more hyped but I really
think that as I said that we really need
to solve the main problem and this is we
need to find some real-world
applications of quantum computing right
so we don't have that many ideas that's
why algorithmic research is important
and I think machine learning is one of
the areas where we should keep working
on ok I'm not saying that this is the
area where we will find the killer app
but there certainly thing is the area
that we should still looking for
applications ok here are some reasons
why
well the religion for optimism it's
mostly reasons to keep working on on
these things so we do have some powerful
quantum tools right and we have powerful
quantum tools that are very useful for
classical machine learning and these
have to do with linear algebra so if you
go and you look a little bit more
carefully in machine learning there's a
lot of linear algebra happening here and
linear algebra is one of the things that
we kind of know
that quantum computers could help right
so kind of its match there so let's try
to see how can we use these quantum
tools for the linear algebra to say
something interesting about Mozilla the
second is that we also have something
called you can estimate distances
between quantum states if you give I
give you two quantum states and I tell
you how close or far are they then you
can all come up and say I can do a swap
test and I can estimate fast you know
something about the inner product on the
distance of the other states so this is
also something which is useful in
machine learning there's another reason
why I think it's an interesting field is
that machine learning already has to
deal with a lot of noise because the
data is very noisy many times even when
we train neural networks we add
artificial noise while we're training
the neural networks because we want
these things to be very robust against
noise right so I'm not saying that this
is something that necessarily will help
but it's not a bad thing that you know
we need to come up with algorithms that
have to deal with noise quantum
computers will be noisy will might you
know get away with the fact that they're
noisy computations because we do want
the computations to be noisy when we're
doing machine learning in some sense
okay
there's also another thing is that there
are many different things that you may
want to actually do in machine learning
so one of them is let's do things faster
and this is great but there could be
other things that are you know equally
important which is for example things
like explain ability like energy
consumptions like trustworthiness so
these are things that people have
started talking about a lot in machine
learning and there are algorithms that
are more explainable than other ones
maybe they don't give you the best
accuracy but even that if you can you
know do something quantumly better in
that type of algorithm a B you don't get
the best speed or the best accuracy but
you will get other properties like
explain ability right now this becomes
more important the moment you start
talking to people like people in health
care that they want to use machine
learning they cannot use machine
learning if they cannot explain why
they're taking a decision
okay so there are even more reasons why
we should keep working on it and this
has to do with the fact that it's not
obvious how to get real-world
applications in machine learning because
there are also many subtleties in this
so the first thing is that all these
quantum tools that I said about linear
algebra they are very subtle in the
sense that it's not a clear-cut
algorithm that says that okay you give
me the problem I know how it's gonna run
worst case analysis this is what will
happen and you know when you're gonna
get the speed-up on when you're not
going to get a speed-up so you really
have to look a little bit under the rug
and really figure out what matrices are
you dealing with what kind of properties
your data have and all this type of
things can make your algorithm work fast
or not fast at all so somehow you need
to get more into the details of the use
case of what you're trying to solve if
you want to understand whether you know
quantum arguments will give you some
advantage or not okay
there are also issue about how do we
load classical data as quantum states
you know there are also issues about the
fact that all these linear algebra tools
will give you a quantum solution at the
end but at some point you might actually
want the classical solution because you
want to solve the classical problem so
how do you deal with this type of things
and I'll I'll talk more about these
things and the last thing which is a
very big drawback is that we need to
benchmark machine learning and we the
only way to reel 24 machine learning is
whether it works in practice or it
doesn't work in practice and it's very
difficult to write to bench my quantum
machine learning when we don't have the
machines to actually run and see how
things actually run so there are
different ways of dealing with these but
it would be great to have better
machines so we can actually start
testing all these things apart from
starting them or simulating them and
this will come as soon or as not so soon
as Hardware becomes better okay so I
split my talk into tooth into three
different segments one is about
supervised learning the other is about
unsupervised and the third one is about
reinforcement learning these are the
three main topics in machine learning I
will most I would spend most of my time
on supervised learning but I will try to
say a few things about the other two
what towards the end of the of the talk
okay so let's start with classification
I just copied here a list of
applications of classification from
Wikipedia so I don't and it's not half
of them but just to show that the many
applications of classification okay and
I wrote here three different types of
ways that people are trying to do actual
classification okay so what is
classification you have a bunch of data
points some of them are labeled some of
them are not labeled you want to learn
from the labeled data that you have so
that when a new data point comes you can
put a label for example you want a
machine that if you train the machine on
how to recognize handwritten digits or
cats and dogs then at the end if a new
photo comes then the machine should say
this is a cat or this is a dog or this
is a tree or okay so this is kind this
is an image recognition then you can
however also things about test text
natural language processing but the main
ways of trying to solve this problem one
of them is is what I said this has to do
with distances so what do you do when
you want to figure out if your image or
if your data point is you know belongs
to label one or label two you kind of
try to figure out if you're close to
other points that are labeled one or
you're closer to points at a label right
so you take all these data points you
embed them into some space and Euclidian
space and then you try to understand
through your neighborhood you know what
how close are you to specific data
points and this is how you try to assign
a label to yourself somehow okay so
these are things like K nearest neighbor
so near the centroids and things like
that the second thing that is used more
in practice nowadays on how to do
classification has to do neural networks
so you have you take your favorite
neural network it could be a convolution
your network or fully connecting your
network you use train this mural network
on data that are already labeled and the
hope is that at the end your neural
network has been trained enough so that
if a new point comes then it will tell
you the right label at the end okay
other things their thing called support
vector machines you will hear a talk
about this this afternoon and more stuff
so let's look a little bit on the first
one that says about distance estimations
right so this is kind of one photo this
is how let's say near the Centro it
works you have the blue point the green
points and the red points and then a new
point this white one comes into the
picture and you have to say is it gonna
be blue green on red so what do you do
is that you look at the centroids of
these clusters and then you say okay
let's find the nearest centroid then
assign the corresponding label it's kind
of normal
algorithm of this type so as I said
there is one thing that we could try to
do quantumly fast which is exactly try
to figure out what is the distance
between two quantum states okay
so let's assume for now that you know
how to construct this data points U and
V okay as quantum states and I'll
discuss what this means if you know how
to construct let's say U and V you have
a circuit you can construct easily the
state here which is like zero u plus 1 V
so if you kind of control construct the
state and then if you just have them at
the first qubit then you see that the
probability that you get 1 is exactly
proportional to the deep Lydian distance
of the points so of course there is one
more thing that you can do apart apart
from just counting how many zeros and
ones you can do you can also do
something like amplitude estimation and
you can estimate the probability of of
one for example and then in type which
in principle can be quadratically better
than classically you can estimate the
distance between these two points U and
V ok this is a very tiny quantum thing
that one could try to do I'm not saying
that this will save you and will give
you the the killer applications but I'm
just saying that there is a way of
getting some modest improvement which is
the quadratic improvement on estimating
distances between
quantum states okay then the second
thing is I talked about this is neural
networks so this is a big field off of
research so I just copied a few of the
proposals of quantum neural network
architectures and what they look like I
don't understand all of them but the
main idea is the following the main idea
is that you start let's say with an
image you you embed the image into a
number of qubits and then you have some
sort of quantum circuit which has gates
that have some parameters okay and let's
say you know the first qubit here if
it's zero then you should say cut and if
it's one it's supposed to be a dog so
you start with something that it's some
sort of random circuit that doesn't give
you the correct answer many times and
then what you do is that little by
little using the data that you already
know the labels you try to figure out
what this parameter should be so that at
the end you know you are mostly correct
on this label of cat and dogs and if
you're mostly correct on on the data
that you already know you hope that when
the new image comes then this your
network will actually you know also give
you the right label of of image so this
is kind of the idea so classically this
is exactly the same there are parameters
which have to do with the weights that
you use in order to go from one neuron
to the twin neuron of the next level
here the idea is is that you just start
with some unit Ares in some parameters
and you try to figure out what this
parameters should be okay I think Xiao D
after my talk will talk more about how
to use this type of things to do some
interesting
so it's it's an interesting question so
to be fairly honest there are many of
these proposals that don't even talk
about training so there are proposals
that talk about training and the
training is some sort of gradient
descent computation some sarcastic
grating yes okay so it's an interesting
research area we have some small
examples that these things could
actually work okay it's very difficult
to benchmark these things because we
don't have these quantum circuits to
actually run in in sizes that will
actually make sense to understand
whether they will scale well and whether
they will work well okay it's one
comment that I also want to make is that
this type of techniques can be very
useful for specific type of problems
like start with a circle with some
parameters and try to figure out what
these parameters are but certainly not
all problems are amenable to this type
of techniques
there was blood post by Scott recently
that kind of says the obvious that you
should not expect to solve factoring for
example with this type of techniques but
whether you can actually do something
interesting with classification why not
I mean classical neural networks work so
it's possible that we figure out nicely
how to work with these things okay so we
also did some work on on your networks
but here we tried more to to look at
classical neural network so we don't
want to define a new model with we
looked at the the classical neural
networks and the question was can I do
the training faster through a quantum
algorithm right and as we said the
quantum al that the algorithm for
training has to do with gradient descent
so there's a lot of matrix
multiplications and linear algebra and
this is where we want to use quantum
linear algebra to do something
interesting here you can start getting
gains just from the fact that you can
use some sort of estimation of the inner
product of these things this is not
going to give you too
again like I think the best you can hope
compared to classical ways would be a
quadratic speed-up on one of the terms
but this could be interesting and then
we also looked at convolution in your
networks where there is a little bit
more work to be done because they're all
the different kind of operations that
one does on a convolutional neural
network this was a paper from icy Ella
okay so the main channel for this to me
is how to combine two things right we do
want to look at quantum your networks
that we can actually implement like in
the misc era and these are not like that
so we have to go back to the previous
one at the same time it would be good to
have some provable guarantees so now
what do I mean by provable guarantees
for a neural network it's you know even
for classical euler networks we
sometimes we don't know why they
actually work but there are statements
that you can try to prove here for
example you can say that at least it can
do as well as a class as the equivalent
classical you network for example we do
better maybe I don't know how to prove
that it can do better but can we at
least prove something of the form you
know if the classical equivalent neural
network would work then this could at
least do as well as that so this type of
you know trying to find some sort of
evidence why we would believe that these
quantum yura networks would actually
work or not okay so there is one other
thing that I want to discuss a bit on
classification and this is very
interesting when we will start talking
about the input is the fact that many
times when I give you the data as an
image let's look at the emmys data set
is like 780 something pixels the first
one thing you can try to do is just use
exactly that as your input right you
just write down the vector that
corresponds to the pixel this gives you
some sort of data point then you start
trying to classify with these points
right but many times what people
actually do is before doing that they
try to they map all these data points
into a space where the classification is
much easier or much more accurate to do
right so these are all this type of
techniques that are called for example
the machine malady reduction so you
would think that the Machine a little
reduction reduces the the dimension
which is true and why would it be better
and keeping all the dimensions but many
times what you do is actually you start
from your input you go to a bigger
dimension and then you bring it down to
a smaller dimension and somehow this
gives you the tips the information that
you need and gets rid of the information
that you don't need right so these are
things like principal component analysis
linear discriminant slow feature
analysis so all these type of things try
to find the best way of embedding your
data into a new space and then using
some normal classification algorithm
within that space and why is this
interesting because here in the
classical the reason why these are you
know are difficult to use in practice is
because this is some much heavier linear
algebra now right so all these kind of
techniques have to do with basically
looking at the eigenspaces of these
matrices like you need to find
eigenvectors you can project on the top
i can space or for example you look at
the low i can space of the covariance
matrix of your data so there is some
more heavy heavy linear algebra that has
to happen here and this is again one
place where quantum can actually do
something better because you know we can
hope that quantum can do this type of
linear algebra operations faster okay so
there have been results on on quantum
ways of doing this type of
dimensionality reduction okay so we use
some sort of phantom linear algebra to
do this mapping from one space to the
other and then as I said you can use
whether you want a network or you can
use linear the centroid type
classification algorithms to work in
this new space here is a way of actually
doing this type of things in a quantum
way that can actually provide some
advantage to you so I think we probably
everyone has had the phase estimation
algorithm I gives you is unitary I gives
you a n vector of the unitary then what
the quantum computer can do fast is
basically estimate that I can value that
corresponds to this eigenvector okay so
now the singular value estimation is
basically an extension of the phase
estimation that says that okay if you
give me a major
which may not be unitary but let's say
it's a symmetric matrix for now it has
some decomposition on eigenvectors and
eigenvalues and then there exists a
quantum algorithm that exists a circuit
that if the input is an eigenvector of
this matrix then it will estimate the
corresponding eigenvalue okay it's not
going to give you exactly the eigenvalue
is there gonna be like an epsilon
approximation of this eigenvalue and the
good thing is that you can't do this in
two in superposition right it's a
quantum so how does this relate to to
doing these things so here is a very
simple example so imagine that what I
want to do is that I want to project a
vector all to the eigen space of this
matrix that has high eigen values okay
so let's say I have a threshold T and I
want to project B on the sub Biden space
of a with eigenvalues that are more than
this threshold T okay so here is a
simple way of understanding how we can
do it is not necessarily the best way
when it comes to the errors but it's
easy to to explain you start with your
vector okay and you can imagine that
this vector has some decomposition in
the eigen space of the matrix you don't
have to know it okay but it can be
written you know in this way and then if
you feed this vector here which is just
your initial vector into this procedure
then what will happen is that next to
you each one of the eigenvectors should
come up with an estimate of the
eigenvalue of the singular value that's
it okay and then once you have this
value here which is like a number that
you write with some digits then you can
do a simple operation that says that
okay look at lambda if lambda is more
than T put a 0 if lambda is less than T
then put a 1 so some sort of threshold
gate which is a simple thing to do look
at this register keep the ones that are
bigger than a threshold get rid of the
ones that are smaller than a threshold
okay and then if you measure zero or if
you post select here on zero then the
state here and then you one compute the
lambda the stage here is exactly what
you would want for something like this
which is the projection of the vector
all to some part of the eigen space of
this matrix
here we did the top I can space it could
be them also there's nowhere I can space
you can decide things that have to do
with with the eigenvalues of this matrix
okay so this is another case where you
have this quantum arguments for linear
algebra that can help you in doing some
more complicated classification
algorithms okay so what is the runtime
of these things yeah yes so either you
do basically what you can do is you do
amplitude amplification so that you end
up with this state or if you know how to
construct the stage this measure until
you get 0 if you want slower but faster
algorithm so what are the parameters
that come into this linear algebra
things we usually talk about three
parameters this Kappa has to do with the
condition number of the matrices like
what is the lowest eigen value of the
matrix nu is something that could be the
sparsity of the matrix or could be the
Frobenius norm of the matrix or it could
be something like the max l1 norm of the
rows of the matrix so there different
ways of constructing these matrices that
you are gonna get different parameters
here ok but this is something that
depends on your on your date on your
matrix is it sparse is it well you know
is it sparse does it have a low rank or
high rank what is the forbidden of
different you can decide which way to
embed your matrix so that you can get
different parameters mu here and then
there is a parameter epsilon which
depends on how well you are doing the
singular value estimation there are
algorithms that actually produce quantum
stage with log 1 over Epsilon ok but if
you want to actually look at this then
the samples that you will need is again
1 over epsilon square so somehow there
is a 1 over epsilon you know more log 1
over epsilon depending on what you claim
you have at the end of the quantum
procedures
so the different things for example here
the Kappa is very simple the Kappa is
like T over ten right so as long as your
T is something reasonable for example it
could be one of the rank if you want the
top K rank things then your Kappa is
basically this threshold the most
difficult thing would be when you really
want to do a the inversion of the matrix
to solve the linear system and then you
have to care about the the smallest
eigen eigen values let's say right when
you do matrix multiplication you don't
care about this couple this Kappa
shouldn't appear in the running time of
a matrix multiplication algorithm for
example right so again depends on what I
mean linear algebra is not the same I
mean matrix multiplication in linear
systems is not exactly the same thing
even though it's the same and to the bag
it's not the same thing somehow okay I
wanted to talk about ten minutes I have
about recommendation systems very
briefly it's one slide and a half so
this is kind of the first example that
we came up with a few years ago on well
here is a application of quantum machine
learning obviously you need a very big
nice quantum computer but at least if
you would have your favorite quantum
computer then you could be able to do
something and why do we think that you
can do something because the
Commendation systems it's it's basically
linear algebra
it's basically completing a matrix for
which you have a little bit of
information knowing that the matrix has
a good low-rank approximation if you
look at the algorithms then it ends up
that you have to do the singular value
estimation because the main point
recommendation systems is again you need
to do some sort of singular value
decomposition you need to project your
rows into the top eigen space of this of
this completed matrix somehow okay so I
kind of showed you how you can do this
type of projections through the singular
value estimation and this gave you some
sort of competitive recommendations you
know few years ago I would say
exponentially faster so now I say fast
and the reason is that you know here
is a little bit what the the running
time of these things are so here is the
quantum thing the quantum thing depends
on the types let's say the types of the
users is basically the rank of the
matrix or the Frobenius norm of the
matrix so this is something fairly small
compared to the dimension okay but it
only depends logarithmically on the
dimension of the matrix right and this
we were kind of contrasting to to the
work that we did a long time ago with on
recommendation systems that you know
it's also coincidence I was an intern
with one of Ravis students Petros and
with from high Caraga van it was exactly
the time where they were coming up with
this amazing kind of techniques for
randomized linear algebra and when we're
looking at it we said okay the
commutation system is the right
application to apply it so we came up
with how to do recommendation system
based on the see you are techniques for
randomized linear algebra I think that
we will talk more about this and the
running time there was you know again
type squared times the products so this
is why we were claiming the exponential
speed-up because we don't have to depend
on the products anymore you can go to
the log of the products okay so this was
kind of the story until 2017 and then
there was some really good work by
aeverine tank force we will give a talk
after the break who said that ok so this
is what you get if you look at the sea
you are based techniques but there were
some techniques which were there even
before which is the kV techniques but
actually do not have to depend on the
dimension they can also depend on the
log of the dimension you don't have to
pay a penalty and it's kind of a steep
penalty that you know I think we
shouldn't neglect that the polynomial on
the number of types that you have here
is something like 20 to the power of 24
I looked at this paper which I think
it's improving on this paper which if
you just put some sort of numbers that
happen for the Amazon matrix you get
something which is the number of the
atoms of the universe but this doesn't
mean that this algorithms this this is
what somehow the theoretical bound keeps
you and I will discuss a little bit more
what these numbers mean okay so as you
see now here we only have a polynomial
gap because this is log and this is log
and this is types and this is poly types
but somehow you might even get a bigger
gap than you have before because you
know polynomials can be bad sometimes
okay so in the last five minutes I will
try to discuss a little bit a couple of
things that you know maybe it would be
good to understand because this will
tell us how to try to keep working on
finding real world applications the
first one is about loading data on
quantum states okay so this is one of
the problems that people say that okay
but if you want to run your quantum
Marconi's you assume that you have this
quantum axis meaning that you have
quantum access to this classical data
how are you going to build this type of
things so the first thing you know the
answer is that you try so you try
because first answer could be that even
come to me puts khalaq should be very
interesting sometimes and I think sure
they will talk about this you do have
you do have applications where your
input is by by itself quantum it's not
classical data that you have to take
into quantum inputs you have quantum
data that come from circuits that you
want to train for example you want to
understand the behavior so there are
things that quantum machine learning can
do for quantum inputs so then you
obviously don't have the problem of
taking classical data there are also
many cases where the input is actually
easy to construct so what do I mean by
that so these are the cases where the
the the input is not cats and dogs but
these are inputs that you can actually
have a function that actually computes
inputs for you so this for example the
case when you try to do P DS like
partial differential equations through
neural networks there your data is
actually looking at your at your PD and
computing the value of the PD on some
specific points on some points on your
grid so this is your data which is easy
to construct in the sense that you just
apply your PD and you find the values
right so there's no extra classical data
that you would have to somehow figure
out a way of accessing quantity there is
a circuit there is a classical circuit
that computed
for you to train your new neural network
that then it will give you the correct
answer for all your space like somehow
that the function that the neural
network would compute at the end is the
is the solution to your PD right it's
also the case for reinforcement learning
for example where your data has to do
with your transition matrix and many
times the transition matrix you know
what it is you have a robot in a room
you know that the robot can go back
front left and right so again there is
no external data that you have to
remember or you know put into interim
you can construct your data as you go
okay these are not the cases then you
also have ways of loading classical data
on quantum states these circuits that
have or the Desai's meaning that if you
want to upload a D dimensional vector
then you have to pay D on some resource
okay but you could do it in a way that
the depth of the circuit is only log D
so you could say that the circuits could
actually be running in log D time as I
said another case is when your your
quantum input is not really your input
but it's the input after you did some
heavy linear algebra on it like you
project it on to the principal
components so something like that so
there the bottleneck is not really
uploading the classical data in the into
the quantum data is how you do the
linear algebra so you can even afford to
pay linear on the dimension or linear on
the data set because classically you
already pay like cubic or the data set
if you want to do this type of
pre-processing
okay so this is another way that you
could be getting a polynomial speed-up
without having to assume anything that
you can do on how to upload the quantum
data and sometimes it will not work
so I think the point is that we should
really try to understand when it works
when it doesn't work and for what
applications didn't make sense so on the
output again the question is you have
this quantum linear algebra techniques
you have this quantum algorithms you
come up with a quantum solution at the
end how do you get from this quantum
solution to a classical solution of the
classical problem that you're trying to
solve okay so sometimes the quantum
states are good enough and they're good
enough because you just need to sample
from the solution you don't need to
write down the classical solution so
this is the case for the Commendation
systems or for classification for
example sometimes it's not enough and
when is it not enough usually when you
want to do a tentative methods meaning
that you have some linear system that
you want to solve and then the solution
of this linear system kind of defines
the next linear system that you would
want to solve so there you have to
define your next linear system so you
need the classical information of this
quantum state right so there what do you
do you have to pay more so you have to
pay more you have to figure out ways of
coming you know getting the classical
information out of the quantum states
again you have to pay a lot you have to
pay proportional to the dimension if you
want l2 guarantees okay it is in many
cases it is the case that L infinity
guarantees are good enough for you so
this is the case for example in
reinforcement learning so all the
convergence happens in L infinity this
is also the case with all these new
linear programming classical algorithms
where L infinity guarantees are good
enough and any field the guarantees are
much easier to get done l2 guarantees
right so you need the one over epsilon
square samples from this stage which are
independent of the dimension of the
state to get an epsilon close in L
infinity classical description of of
this quantum state
so this is another operation which is
quite interesting to me what is the best
classical linear system solution that
gives you a lean Finiti guarantees not
l2 guarantees for l2 guarantees we kind
of know what's happening many cases we
need the limb finiti guarantees we know
how to do it
quantumly the nice and fast way what
would be the best classical way for
doing this it's not clear ok again in
some cases it's not going to work
and maybe I finished with this slide so
how do we benchmark how do we know if
it's going to work or if it's not going
to work it's it's it's it's not clear I
think that there's no clear answer to
this and especially I want to make sure
that we all understand that there is no
one bit answer that will resolve this
issue so I think the question of is it
an exponential order polynomial speed-up
I think it's a very important question
because it kind of forces us to look at
the right theoretical models between the
quantum in the classical thing and
really you know compare the right things
with the right things ok but if the
answer is that we're gonna get
polynomial speed-up which is actually
the case this does to me it's not the
end of the story ok so as we said many
times the polynomial gaps could be
bigger even than the exponential gaps
for where you care about ok but what it
really matters is the practical scaling
right so for example if we look at this
algorithm
there's no way that anything to the 24
is actually going to work but the
question is is this really the thing or
is it just a matter of you know making
this better or can we get better things
so I I don't know so this is very good
questions like how well how much can we
push this fkv type techniques to get
more practical running times right so
some people did some experiments and
they showed actually that the good news
and bad news in the sense that this type
of algorithms have significantly smaller
run times and their worst case
complexity so they don't run as K to the
twenty-something ok but still they're
worse than the classical the previous
classical algorithms so there are likely
to alter the set of problems where
quantum Al Gore's may have a practical
impact in the sense that you you
obviously you have to compare with
both okay so we need to figure out you
know which one of these is better or
actually use both of them but somehow it
still opened whether this quantum
running time can be done in a way it can
be seen in practice yeah so this one is
this one is Robin I put it like this is
the recommendation system it depends so
it depends on what you use from linear
algebra if you do simple things like in
a product estimation then you get you
get kind of a quadratic slowdown if you
do things like projections as VDS and
things like that then you get bit bigger
things if you do even more complicated
things like interior point like try to
solve support vector machines then I
think I'm not wrong but the exponent
that they have that the paper has is 88
so linear algebra is not the same it
depends on what you want to do and and
what I'm trying to say is that the
quantum things can do heavy linear
algebra stuff and maybe this is where we
can expect to get some speed up because
this is really where the classical
methods failed so okay so it's a more
different question and I'm done here
thank you
the time for question where the next
[Applause]